صرح وزير العدل التركي عبد الحميد غول بان
بلاده لن تسمح باغلاق قضيه اغتيال جمل
الخشيه وتعهد بمتابعتها حتى النهايه على
مستوى الامم المتحده وايا كان مسار
الاليات التي ستتبع دوليا في هذا الشان
واشار الى ان تركيا ارسلت للسلطات
السعوديه طلبت تسليم ثمانيه عشر شخصا
تورطوا في هذه القضيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان هذا خبر
حلقتنا ونناقش فيما وراءه على ماذا تعول
تركيا لابقاء قضيه اغتيال جمال الخشيه على
الصعيد الدولي والى متى تستمر السلطات
السعوديه في التعويل على عامل الوقت
لتجاوز تداعيات هذه القضيه وطي ملف ها
[موسيقى]
ليست هذه المره الاولى التي تتحدث فيها
تركيا عن السعي الى اجراء تحقيق دولي في
قضيه اغتيال جمال خاشقجي
غير ان التصريحات التركيه تترافق هذه
الايام مع الاشاره الى تعاون مع دول اخرى
لاحاله الامر الى الامم المتحده
والى التحرك عبر الانتربول لتسليم ثمانيه
عشر شخصا من المتورطين في هذه القضيه ياتي
هذا مع نشر وسائل اعلام تركيا وامريكيه
تفاصيل جديده عن قضيه خارجي واضافه ثلاثه
متهمين الجدد الى القضيه والكشف عن ان
عددا من المتهمين يعيشون احرارا في
السعوديه نبدا النقاش بعد تقرير مريم
الوقت لن يكون قضيه جمال خاشقجي ولن يسقط
التهم التي تطارد قتلته بالتقادم التاكيد
لتركيا التي وقعت على ارضها الجريمه
المروعه يوميا تتكشف جوانب مظلمه من
تفاصيله تقشعر لها الابدان تعهد وزير
العدل التركي عبد الحميد جول ان انقره
ستواصل التحقيقات في القضيه حتى النهايه
على مستوى الامم المتحده والمجتمع الدولي
مذكرا بان السلطات بلاده ارسلت الى الرياض
طلب تسليم ثمانيه عشر شخصا مع التاكيد على
احقيه انقره في محاكمه المشتبه فيهم يضيف
غير ان السلطات ستتابع مسار ما يعرف بال
نشرات الحمراء للمتهمين مع الشرطه
الجنائيه الدوليه الانتربول وطلبات تسلمهم
وللمره الالف يعبر المسؤولون الاتراك عن
عدم رضاه بسبب غياب التعاون المطلوب من
الجانب السعودي استنكر وزير الخارجيه
مولود شو شو طلبات السعوديه المستمره
لانقره بتقديم معلومات في حين تتجاهل
الرياض الكشف عن المتعاون المحلي
المتعاون المحلي بدا عندما اعترفت وبعد
طول انتظار وفي روايه منقوصه الرياض
باغتيال الخارجيه داخل القنصليه لكن هو
حتى اللحظه لم تكشف عن اسمه ومكانه بعد
ضغوط دوليه ارسلت رسما تقريبا لن يساعد
المحققين في الشيء يقول الاتراك عكس رهان
البعض على عامل الزمن حتى تنسى القضيه
تكشف اسماء وتفاصيل جديده عما حدث في ذلك
المقر الديبلوماسي في يوم الثاني من
اكتوبر المشؤوم على الصحافه وحريه التعبير
نشرت صحيفه الصباح التركي اسماء ثلاثه
مشتبه فيهم جدد شاركوا في الجريمه يتعلق
الامر باحمد عبد الله بن زين وهو رئيس
وحده اسطنبول في المخابرات السعوديه وال
سعد مؤيد الجرمي ومثل الشارع المصلح
اللذين عمل حارسين وهو في الاصل في
المخابرات وكان ضمن فريق التخلص من شرطه
المرور
التقرير الصادر من صحيفه الصباح وخاصه من
الجزء المتعلق باللحظات الاولى لاغتيال
الخارجي ولد فيه ايضا ان صلاح الطبيعي
الطبيب الشرعي ومسؤول عمليات تقطيع الجثه
يعيش حرا مع عائلته في جده ثمه عدد اخر من
المتهمين يعيشون بحريه في المملكه ولكن
معزولين عنو حيت هم لم يذكر القضاء
السعودي اسماء المتهمين لديه على خلفيه
قضيه شوهت صوره المملكه اكثر مما فعلته
احداث الحادي عشر من سبتمبر ولم تغير
قرارات القصر سواء تعلق الامر باعاده
هيكله جهاز المخابرات او اقاله مقربين من
ولي العهد او التغيير الوزاري الاخير موقف
المجتمع الدولي الغاضب من الجريمه جريمه
قال اعضاء في الكونغرس الامريكي انها كشفت
تهور ولي العهد السعودي
محمد بن سلمان مجلس الشيوخ بتركيبته
القديمه والجديده لن يتسامح كما يبدو مع
من امر بقتل
بها السلطات السعوديه على عامل الوقت ل
اغلاق الملف المسائل سمعتها وفق ما يقول
المراقبون خاسر ومن الان فال سنوات لم
تمنع جلب اثنين الشيء سلوبودان ميلوسوفيتش
وغيرهما الى العداله الدوليه وان تعذر
تشوفي حتى من هذا ربما لن يكون الامر كذلك
بشان تحقيق العداله لروحه ولا بناءه
موضوع حلقتنا اليوم نناقشه مع ضيفينا من
عمان عبر الانترنيت الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي عمرو من اوهايو البروفيسور جون
كويس لي استاذ القانون الدولي في جامعه
اوهايو معك سيدي نبدا هل تعتقد ان بامكان
تركيا متابعه القضيه قضيه مقتل حتى
النهايه كما وعدت وابقاء هذه القضيه حيه
على المستوى الدولي
تركيا بالتكريم كان بامكانها متابعه هذه
القضيه على المستوى الدولي فتمت الطريق
واضح في الامم المتحده
لامكانيه القيام
بتحقيق رسمي في هذا الموضوع وفي الواقع ان
هذا امر دعا اليه عدد عدد من المسؤولين في
الامم المتحده نفسها فعلا فهناك عدد من
المسؤولين في الامم المتحده
هم المسؤولون عن مثل هذه القضايا مثل قضيه
حقوق التحق حريه التعبير والقتل خارج حدود
القانون الاختفاء القسري للاشخاص وكلهم
هؤلاء ادعوا الى اجراء تحقيق رسمي يمكن
القيام به اما تحت رعايه الامين العام
للامم المتحده او تحت رعايه
او مجلس حقوق الانسان في الامم المتحده
سيد عمر عناصر البعض يرى بان القضيه وصلت
الى حدودها القصوى من جهه المعلومات
والتفاصيل التي باتت معروفه للجميع او
بالنسبه للتفاعل الدولي الذي وصل الى حد
الاقصى لكنه لم يغير في واقع الامور شيئا
يعني انا بقول انه قد تكون المعلومات
لازال في جعبه الاتراك بعض المعلومات
والدليل التسريبات الاخيره عن اسماء جديده
لا ادري يعني ما الذي يخفيه الاتراك ومتى
يطلقون صراحه يعني هذه مساله اه اخرى لكن
انا باعتقادي ان القضيه لم تبرد اه لا
يوجد في السياسه ولا يوجد في علاقات الدول
قضايا تبرد هي يعاد انتاجها في التوقيت
والتوظيف السياسي المناسب وبالتالي انا
بقول انه الاتراك معنيين بهذه المساله
بشكل كبير هناك هدفي الكرامه الوطنيه يجعل
هم يهتمون بها بشكل اكبر اليوم وزير العدل
تحدث بالامس وزير الخارجيه قبله زعماء
المعارضه اه نتحدث عن كرامه وطني من جهه
اخرى اه الاتراك لم يكتفوا في قصه التوظيف
السياسي بمعنى اه لا زال امامهم الكثير
اللي يستفيدوا من هذه القضيه في عالم
التوظيف السياسي اما القول ان القضيه وصلت
الى نهايتها ليس بعد اه في قادم الايام
سيكون هناك مشكله بين المجتمع السياسي
الامريكي وبين الترام في ملفات كثيره
واحده من هذه الملفات ستكون قضيه قضيه
قضيه علاقه ولي العهد السعودي ب اه كوشنير
وبترا بالعلاقه الشخصيه بمعنى ان هذا
الملف اه ل يوجد في بنيته الذاتيه قابليه
للانتاج اه في اي لحظه وفي اي اليوم تمر
الظروف ربما انسحاب الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من سوريا الاتفاقات الروسيه
وقصه من بدك لهذا قد تغطي على اه وزن
وقيمه والبريق لقصه شافني لكن قطعا انه
سيعاد انتاج وسعاده وظيفه وسيعادي الضغط
مره اخرى على العربيه السعوديه في هذا
الملف من اه جانبين الاتراك والامريكان
على السواء سيد من وجهه نظرك كيف تفهم في
التوقيت السياسي مزيد من المعلومات التي
تنشرها الصحف التركيه وفي التوقيت السياسي
ايضا تاكيد وزير العدل التركي الذهاب حتى
النهايه في اه هذه القضيه والعمل مع دول
اخرى
بالتاكيد هناك امكانيه
انه يمكن متابعه هذه القضيه عن طريق
الحكومه نفسها
بالتعاون مع اعضاء اخرين في الامم المتحده
وخاصه عن طريق مجلس حقوق الانسان في الامم
المتحده
ويمكن ايضا يكن هناك بعض النشاطات عن طريق
الشرطه الدوليه الانتربول كما يسمى ب
الاشاره الحمراء التي او الاعلام ال اه
الاحمر الذي هو اه عمليه اعلان عن اعتقال
شخص خطر جرى تحت تعريفه بالنسبه بالنسبه
من تركيا على ان هو او هم المسؤولون عن
شيء السيد عمر عياصره اه كشف المعلومات
الجديده وتاكيد التركي الجديد اه هل له
دلاله اليوم تحديدا في هذا التوقيت الذي
اشرت الى بعض اه يعني ملابساته
يعني اهم دلالاتها اننا نملك المزيد من
المعلومات لازلنا نحقق لازلنا نسخن هذه
القضيه نحن صحيح تركيا مشغولون ب ملفات
اخرى لكن هذا الملف اه مهم ومهم جدا ويعني
لابد من ابقاءه في حاله اه حياه يعني صحيح
ان نضعه في الخارج احيانا لكن قد اخرجه
احيانا الى العلم هذا هو المعنى اه من
اعاده مره اخرى انتاج القضيه من قبل
الاتراك والتصريحات للمسؤولين والحديث عن
التدويل والحديث عن التقصير السعودي
والحديث عن المتعاون واليوم الحديث عن اه
اطراف اخرى كان هم يقولون ان لدينا المزيد
لا يمكن ان اه ترتاحوا يعني وهنا يتحدثون
ويخاطب السعوديه ان ترتاح وان معلوماتنا
انتهت وان المخزون المعلومات انتهت على ما
يبدو ان الاتراك لديهم من التسهيلات ما
يكفي لكن يحتاجون الى اللحظه السياسيه
اللحظه المناسبه التوقيت المناسب اعاده
عوده اشتباك المجتمع السياسي الامريكي
بهذا الملف لكن في النهايه كل ما قدموا
معلومه جديده جديده كلما اربكوا المفهوم
السعودي بان الوقت يقتل القضيه هذا هو
غايه الاتراك الاتراك احد اهم الروافع
لاستمرار هذه القضيه هي سواء على مستوى
التركي على المستوى الدولي او اعاده انتاج
في المجتمع الامريكي من خلال التواصل مع
الصحافه والمجتمع السياسيه جنجويد لي اه
هل تلاحظ ان هناك تجاوب دولي مع تركيا في
هذه القضيه مازال قائما حتى اليوم
اعتقد ان
تتخذ موقفا قويا للغايه وب كان ان تواصل
هذه القضيه حتى اكثر من ذلك
واذا ما حصل تحقيق عن طريق الامم المتحده
فان ذلك يشكل ضغوطا على كل من تركيا
والسعوديه في ان واحد ليكشف كل المعلومات
المتوفره لديهما اه حول هذه القضيه
وحتى
المعلومات التي
لدي الدول الاخرى حكومات اخرى مثلا اه
وكاله المخابرات الامريكيه السي اي ايه
وكل هذه المعلومات يمكن ربطها سويه
وضبطها ببعضها للتوصل الى الصوره كامله
لما حصل فعلا ومن الذي يعتبر مسؤولا على
ذلك الحالي الح فلدينا شريفه قد ارتكبت
على في تركيا والتركي لها كل الحق ان ان
تقوم بالتحقيق الاجراميه سيدلي اه باختصار
هل تعتقد ان بامكان
اه الامم المتحده ان تتحرك من دون موافقه
مجلس الامن بمعنى دون موافقه الدول الكبرى
دائمه العضويه في مجلس الامن تحديدا
الولايات المتحده
المؤثر والفعال
لو ان مجلس الامن تدخل في هذا الموضوع لان
للمجلس مجلس الامن سلطات اقوى ولكن في هذا
الوقت هناك احتمال وامكانيه ان
التوصل الى قرار في مجلس الامن والولايات
المتحده قد لا تصوت لصالحه ولكنها قد
تمتنع فقط عن التصويت
وطبعا هذا هناك ضغوط كثيره على رئيس مجلس
الشيوخ الامريكي وايضا من اعضاء حزبه
السياسي الجمهوري ليتخذ موقفا قويا في حول
هذه القضيه على كل مشاهدينا بعد الفاصل
سنناقش امكانيه استمرار تحويل السلطات
السعوديه على عامل الوقت لتجاوز تداعيات
قضيه جمال
وطيباتها الضمان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا في هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش جدوى تعويل السلطات السعوديه
على عامل الوقت في قضيه مقتل جمال خاشقجي
في ضوء تعهد تركيا بمتابعتها حتى النهايه
بدعم المجتمع الدولي اعود الى ضيفي عمر
عياصره من عمان اه سيد عمر الى اي مدى
تعتقد بان التعويل السعودي على عامل الوقت
من اجل نسيان القضيه من اجل جميعها خصوصا
وان هناك قضايا دوليه اخرى مرشحه ايضا اه
تتفاعل الى اي مدى يمكن ان يكون مجديا هذا
الامر
اه الرياض تفكر بهذا الموضوع ومن بدايه
الازمه تحاول ان اه تتعامل مع عامل الوقت
وتبريد القضيه بشيء من الاهتمام وهذا يفسر
سخونه وهدوء في كثير من الاحيان لكن هل
ذلك قيمه انا باعتقادي ان الرياض واقع
اليوم تحت تاثير قضيه خاص هذه الخسائر
التي تتحقق في اليمن ان يفرض عليها
المجتمع الدولي هذا السلوك السياسي الجديد
في اليمن من وقف القتال الى التسويه
السياسيه والاعتراف بالحوثيين اعتقد انه
من تداعيات قتل خاصه ما جرى في سوريا هذه
الانسحابات هذا الانكفاء السعودي هو منتدى
حتى ما يجري في الداخل من تغييرات مرتبكه
احيانا ليست ذات طعم ووزن ولغه واضحه
باعتقادي انه كله تحت ضغط قضيه لكن
السعوديه في النهايه تراهن على الوقت ان
تموت القضيه لكن اذا كان في هناك حكمه
وحنكه لابد ان يفكروا ان هذه القضايا في
جعبه الدول وفي العلاقات السياسيه لا تموز
يعاد انتاجها في ايه لحظه وهم يدركون ان
بعد اعياد الميلاد سيعود ال ال النزال بين
القوى السياسيه اه الاحزاب السياسيه
الكونغرس المؤسسه التشريعيه
والاستخباراتيه مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لذلك صحيح انهم يفكرون بقصه
الوقت لكنهم يدركون ان قصه الوقت ليس
عاملا حاسما من يراقب الواشنطن بوست
ونيويورك تايمز والتقارير التي تصدر عن
السعوديه ما قيل عن تهريب هذا الطالب الذي
مائتين بقه الفتاه امريكيه كل هذا يقع في
اطار وفلك قضيه خا شفتي لذلك هم صحيح
يراهنون على الوقت على تبريد القضيه لكن
اعتقد انهم يعملون ايضا على كانت علاقات
عامه تحديدا في المجتمع السياسي الامريكيه
حتى يستميلوا البعض ويخفف من حده الضغط
على طرف لكن في النهايه الوقت سيخدم هم ام
لا هم واقعون تحت الضغط اليوم وغدا
وبالامس او في قادم الايام وباعتقادي
الرهان على الوقت انا شخصيا ارى انها
مساله لا تصلح في علم السياسه وفي عاصمه
في علم الصراعات الدوليه وفي علم التوظيف
السياسي لهذا الملف الثقيل والوازع الذي
اتخذت في قرارات مهمه في المؤسسه
التشريعيه الامريكيه فلا يمكن ان يركن على
الرف مره اخرى سيعاد انتاجه والوقت ليس
لدينا حتى لو عملت عليه الرياض اه كيف
تفهم ان المعلومات التي نشرت عن ان
المسؤولين الذين نفذوا عمليه الاغتيال في
القنصليه السعوديه في اسطنبول يعيشون
احرارا ولو في عزله لكنهم يعيشون في فيلات
مع عائلاتهم احرارا في السعوديه على الرغم
كل ما ذكرته النيابه العامه السعوديه عن
ذلك كيف تفهم هذا الامر
الحكومه السعوديه تقع تحت ضغوط للقيام و
اتخاذ اجراء ما وخاصه لحمايه ولي العهد عن
طريق القاء اللوم على اشخاص اخرين ولكنها
في ذلك اتخذت اجراءات
خفيفه ولائمه جدا ولا عبر الاجراءات اتخذت
لحد الان ستكون مرضيه بالنسبه للمجتمع
الدولي حول هذه القضيه كما ان هناك موضوع
مسؤوليه
الحكومه السعوديه بذاتها بصرف النظر عن من
كان الشخص الذي اصدر امر قتل
فالحكومه السعوديه من الواضح هي المسؤوله
ايضا وبالتالي هذه النقطه التي جرى
التاكيد عليها من قبل مسؤولي الامم
المتحده لحد الان
وذلك سيكون اساسا لاي اجراءات تتخذ في
مجلس حقوق الانسان او في مجلس الامن
التابع للامم المتحده
اه السيد عمر عياصره البعض ربما يقول بانه
اذا كانت القضيه في
اوجهها منذ فتره ولم يكن هناك اي تحرك
دولي حاسم فكيف الان وقد اصبحت اه اه ربما
ليست من الاولويات بالنسبه للدول الغربيه
تحديدا فكيف يمكن ان يكون لها تاثير يعني
هما الساحتين الاهم ين يعني اهم من الساعه
انا شخصيا لا ارى ان الساحه الدوليه هي
الساحه الاهم في قصه ملفي بقدر اهميه
الساحه الامريكيه والساحه اه التركيه
الساحه الامريكيه والساعه التركيه التي
تحرك المجتمع الدولي والتلويح التركي بقصه
التحقيق الدولي هو يعني بدا منذ بواكير
الازمه ولم يخرج عن نطاق التهديد والوعيد
لكن على ما يبدو ان تركيا تريد ان تاخذ
نفس من خلال عده مساقات استمرار التسريب
ان التحقيق يتراكم الجثه وبعض المعلومات
ثم الحديث عن التحقيق الدولي لكن لم تقدم
تركيا على هذه الخطوه الا اذا نضجت شروطها
الظروف الموضوعيه لكن الاهم في ذلك الساحه
الامريكيه الساعه الامريكيه باعتقادي
الرئيس مطالب اه بعد ستين يوم من اقره
الكونغرس باجراءات اه اليوم سياتي كونغرس
جديد س يفتح ملفات كثيره ومتعدده من بينها
تصل في ومن بينها هذا الذي يعول عليه
القضيه في العلاقات الدوليه لا تبرد بقدر
انها تتنحى قليلا ثم تعود مره اخرى اه
للانتاج وعلى فكره ما يجري في الشرق
الاوسط اه من تحرك ومن ديناميكيه عاليه في
الملف اليمني وحتى في الملف السوري كان من
تاثيراته او من احد اسباب الكبيره قضيه
خاشقجي والانتفاء السعودي وتفكك شيء من
التحالف الذي جرى بين السعوديه والامارات
وهو واسرائيل من جهه هذا المشهد بكل
بكليته لا اعتقد انه يفسر ان قضيه خشيه
ستغيب في الظل ستعود مره اخرى تظهر ول
تفرض عضلاتها ول تؤثر على الجميع حتى يتخذ
قرار اه فيها وباعتقادي الساحه الامريكيه
حاسمه وتسخين التركي مؤشر على ذلك في كثير
من الاحيان اه سيد لي اه حاولت
السلطات السعوديه في اه فتره اه قضيه مقتل
ان توجد اجوبه لكل التساؤلات باستثناء
سؤالين رئيسيين
مصير الجثه
واه
المتعاونه المحلي الذي سلمت اليه لماذا
برايك
واعلان يمكن توضيحا هما عن طريق التحقيق
الدولي
اه بالتاكيد انه صحيح ان الس الاسئله
الاساسيه على طريقه تنفيذ هذه الجريمه
الاسئله هذه لم توضح لحد الان وليس واضح
على ان التركي الذي التفكير بيصير معلومات
حول هذه القضيه ام لا ولكن اه هناك تحقيق
لو حصل تحقيق دولي شامل ان ميشيل يؤدي الى
معرفه ما الذي ما هو مصير جثه
وايضا يمكن ان يوضح
هويه هذا الم تعاون المحلي في اسطنبول
الاعلان عن ثلاثه جدد اه هل هو برايك اي
اه مغزى اضافي لهذه القضيه ثلاثه من
المتورطين طبعا
نعم اعتقد
ان كل هذه المبادرات قد تكون فعاله
ولكن من المهم ان هذا الموضوع
يستمر عرضه واعلان عن الحديث عنه بشكل
علني وان احد العناصر الايجابيه والابواب
الايجابيه اه ال اه اللي في مجتمع
الصحفيين هو شعوره بالقلق الموضوع لان
السيد شو كان عضوا من الاسره الصحفيه
والمهمه الصحفيه وبالتالي هذا عنصر مهم
لابقاء هذا الموضوع حيا
امام الجماهير بشكل مستمر سيد عمر عياصره
اشرت الى انه ال
يعني عامل الوقت عامل اساسي تراهن عليه
السعوديه طيب ما الذي يمنعها من اتخاذ
اجراءات ولو كما يقال لذر الرماد في عيون
المجتمع الدولي بالنسبه لاولئك الذين
وردت اسماؤهم وتاكد انهم تورطوا في عمليه
الاغتيال حتى تتركهم احرارا واه يعيشون
على عكس ما قالته النيابه العامه
هي تقول انه هناك معتقلين هي ربما لا
تعترف بان هم احرار و و يطلق سراحهم لكن
هي تدرك السعوديه ان من اتخذ القرار بقتل
الجمال الخارجيه والمستوى السياسي
وبالتالي حينما يتخذ القرار لا يمكن ان
تقوم بعقوبه هؤلاء بالشكل التقليدي عليك
ربما اما ان تقضي عليهم نهائيا
واما ان تحاول ان اه تقدم تغطيه لهم
فباعتقادي قصه الداخل السعودي وقصه هؤلاء
لا زالت ليست في حسبان العربيه السعوديه
ولا تستطيع ان تقدم حاله واضحه في في في
في المحاكمه وفي في معاقبتهم هناك اجراءات
ترقى الى مستوى السياسي سعود هناك هناك
ممثل الامر السيد عمر عياصره على ان اه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه غير محرجه او
بالاحرى غير مضطره لا نتقدم الان اه هذا
الامر بما انها ليست تحت الضغط ما رايك
انا انا باعتقادي انها اه لموضوع غير
محرجه غير وارد هي مرتبكه هي لا تعرف ان
تتعامل مع هؤلاء القتله وكيف ستتعامل معهم
على اعتبار انه مرتبطين بمستوى سياسي معين
ثم هي لا تريد ان تقدم تنازلات واضحه في
اطار غير مقبول دوليا لان الجميع يتحدث عن
المسؤول السياسي
ولذلك انا باعتقادي ان الحاله كلها مرتبكه
وقصه الوقت قصه لا قيمه لها اذا ما كانت
هذه القضيه في المجتمع السياسي الامريكي
هم يراقبون الساحتين الاتراك والامريكان
شكرا لك عمر عياصره و شكرا جون ريد لي
شكرا لكم مشاهدينا والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]